what's up guys
bang bang it's lunch money time i'm here
with the intelligent polina pompano
who has a amazing i actually like this
it's soft it looks like a cheetah looks
like you are ready to take on the world
what's up while while she's trying to
get rid of us that's just trying to get
our lunch money right don't forget that
lunch money is now sponsored by block
five
block five allows you to buy and sell
crypto you can take out a us dollar loan
and get your crypto collateral or you
can earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account if
you have a block buy account you can
also now sign up
for the waitlist for the bitcoin rewards
credit card you use your credit card but
rather than get airline miles or dollars
back
you get bitcoin no brainer go sign up
blockbuy.com
blockfly.com uh before we start with the
topics i have an announcement
spammers get out of the comments if
you see that somebody with anthony's
name has commented on your post
it's probably a spam or if they're
asking you to send somebody whatsapp
or money off i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
ask you that and
if it's actually him uh his name is
highlighted on youtube so that's how you
know
yeah i'm not gonna ask you for nothing
he ain't gonna ask for it i don't need
money i don't need your whatsapp number
i don't need you to message me we're
good if i comment it'll just be a bunch
of
exclamation points saying let's go don't
be sending people money on the internet
okay all right let's go paypal ceo dan
shulman said the use of digital
currencies is set to go mainstream as
more merchants take a digital first
approach to payments the entire world is
going to come into digital first he said
um
shops are moving to accept payments via
smartphones and qr codes even in store
and more customers are
going to start using digital wallets
which are neutral complement
are natural natural complements to
digital currencies
of course duh this is going to happen
the question is not
whether it's going to happen it's when
and how is it going to happen
sequentially what's going to occur are
people going to use bitcoin are they
going to use other currencies
how does this play out that is the big
question we don't know
but what we do know is that the end
state is everyone's got a digital wallet
and everyone's using digital currencies
get ready because the world's coming
another
person who is sounding bullish on
bitcoin
blackrock's larry fink said bitcoin has
caught the attention and the imagination
of many people
still untested pretty small market
relative to other markets
sounds almost bullish larry fink
is the co-founder and ceo of the largest
asset manager in the world
7.5 trillion dollars
they're bullish on bitcoin they're not
out here accidentally saying these
comments
they're definitely looking they're
trying to figure it out and i wouldn't
be surprised if the next thing we see
is blackrock rolling out products
or helping their clients get exposure to
bitcoin
the people who are coming in to this
asset now it's a 350 360 billion dollar
asset
it is so undervalued it's not even funny
so get ready we'll see what happens bang
bang by the way i don't think that you
have this on here
but another person who was born peter
jones
paul tudor jones paulina and i's friend
julia uh
she's awesome went ahead on yahoo
finance and she interviewed paul tudor
jones and asked him about bitcoin
and paul tudor jones essentially said
two things one
bitcoin is the new gold right and he
can't believe that the entire crypto
industry is only
uh 500 billion dollars uh he thinks that
it's gonna be worth trillions in the
future so lots of upside
and the second thing he said was that
sovereign nations every single one of
them will have a digital currency in the
future so i have a question why are all
these
rich people coming out and saying they
believe in bitcoin now it's not about
being rich right it's like their job
especially
a larry fink a paul tudor jones their
job is to take a macro view of the world
what is happening in the world and what
is the impact of those events on all the
different assets
so all of a sudden i'm looking at let's
say in the united states there's a bunch
of businesses closed there's government
lockdown still occurring
all kinds of crazy stuff the mayor of
l.a doesn't want to go walk outside
idiot uh uh while that's occurring then
you're gonna get the federal reserve and
elected officials they're gonna step in
they're gonna print money
okay they print money and they keep
interest rates to press for a long
period of time
what impact does that have on real
estate prices oh cheap capital floods
okay real estate prices go up what
impact does that have on equities well
some equities will go up some equities
will go down right
that's their entire job is to understand
how the economy this super complex
interwoven thing operates and then to
make investment decisions based on that
one of the things that is occurring that
is becoming
very very obvious to everyone is that
everyone's going to be using digital
currencies so you see paypal
uh blackrock political drones everyone's
talking about that
and then the second thing is that
there's an entire generation of people
who are let's call it under the age of
35 or 40. there's people over who
believe this as well
but the majority of people under the age
of 35 or 40
grew up with a cell phone in their hand
they have
this digital native type mentality and
so what they're looking at is
they're not going to buy gold they're
not going to buy
traditional assets they're going to buy
those assets in a digitally native way
so you see that through robinhood kind
of trading and things like that
bitcoin is simply operating as a digital
asset
that provides sound money principles
which is what gold historically had done
for kind of the boomer generation
but now these young people or these
millennials
zoomers are literally just buying the
same sound money principles to protect
their wealth and capture upside value
but they're doing it in a new technology
form factor which is bitcoin
and so i think people are just waking up
to that and they're saying wait the
digital world is here like the pandemic
accelerated all these trends and people
are saying the digital world is here
how do we respond i personally don't
know anybody
my age who's buying gold but who knows
would you buy gold what people do on
their own time you know what i'm saying
yeah gold in that ring right there
oh yeah but i'm not buying it oh does
that mean like i can link
okay you could melt it down but i think
that uh somebody in your family would be
very upset
maybe grandma um okay amazon
is an exclusive talks to purchase
podcast startup
wondering according to people familiar
with the matter the wall street journal
reports
as the tech giant pushes further into
the growing audio sector
the talks value wondering at over 300
million dollars
i really thought wondering wasn't that
great what do they do
laundry yeah it's like a it's like a
network of podcasts that you pay for
and they have what revenue of more than
40 million dollars this year
huh you haven't heard of it and what's
the valuation
uh 300 million yeah
what profitability they got what are you
doing
that's a pretty big valuation well
i mean bill simmons was bought for 200
million yeah but you're looking at
spotify
you know picking up all these things and
then
of course it's going to have a high
valuation anything in podcast right now
is going to have a high valuation
maybe your podcast could be 300 million
maybe i should
start taking a little bit more seriously
but yeah that's interesting i don't
think wondering
okay okay uh wondrous investors who
could have a big payday if this goes
through
include waverly capital lear hippa
ventures greycraft partners in advance
at capra i've heard of like two of those
um yeah why is amazon so interesting
us ad revenue for podcasts was only 700
million dollars last year
it's exploded no that's small i know but
it's going to live in a billion dollars
it's gonna be big all right send me this
article i would like to read it and
understand what they're doing
next all right you're going to like this
one yeah let's see
the department of homeland security's
internal watchdog said it would open an
investigation into the use of
mobile phone surveillance technologies
to track americans without a warrant
the latest salvo in a debate within the
us government over the legality of such
techniques and apparently they've been
tracking us for a while
of course they're doing it oh we'll look
into it
we'll look into it yeah you don't need
to look into anything you know you're
doing it
it's been proven you were doing it right
this is the whole edward snowden thing
they were using all sorts of electronic
surveillance
that people weren't aware of and it has
now been determined that it was illegal
their courts had decided that it was
illegal they overstepped their bounds
yeah well if my phone knows where i'm
going i don't know
look we need to protect the united
states right if you're an american you
want to be protected you want to make
sure that there aren't terrorist attacks
that they're
that you can walk to the store you're
not worried about something pulling out
an ak-47 and shooting you in the street
right
it's not a roadside bomb that somebody's
not going to fly a plane into a tower
that when you get on a plane you don't
have to worry about somebody trying to
hijack it like all those things
we need to protect people there is such
a thing as over surveillance
right well there would be an argument
from the most hardcore
uh kind of people around personal
freedoms and individual liberties
that you should not violate the freedom
and the rights
of one individual not one
in order to accomplish that goal so one
senator said if federal agencies are
tracking american citizens without
warrants the public deserves answers and
accountability
i won't accept anything less than a
thorough and swift inspection
inspector general investigation that
sheds light on dhs
dhs phone location data surveillance
program
craziness this is crazy crazy but by the
way they're doing it
duh of course they're doing it why do
you think they they're referring to the
dhs's
phone location tracking program yeah
it's like a program if it's a program
you're definitely doing
it it's a bounce i do want to clarify
one thing
yeah i think that people don't
understand
how much work many of these uh kind of
law enforcement
dhs etc do to keep us safe like i
actually don't think people realize how
many threats there
are at the same time i don't think
people well i also don't think people
realize
how invasive a lot of their surveillance
is
and uh how much rights have been taken
from people
yeah and it's hard once you take
somebody's right to give it back
of course okay ready yeah
two million dollar t-shirts baby the
most complete collection of supreme
t-shirts is being offered for sale at
christie's for about 2 million
highlighting the soaring value of the
luxury streetwear brand
and the growing importance of a new
generation in the collectibles world
collectibles will be big you can tell
them about your art
the collection features 253 shirts which
works out to an average of more than 7
900 per shirt the collection is being
offered as a private sale meaning a
buyer would purchase it directly from
christie's
how much did the shirts originally sell
for unclear
what do you mean unclear we don't know
and the 21 year old has the collection
what yeah that's crazy
that's crazy we are paying 7 900 for a
t-shirt for tell them about your art
oh ferocious the best digital artist in
the world best digital artist
ferocious worked with jason and i and
created
an amazing piece of art of the new york
skyline it's in this
digital piece of art digital piece it's
this pop art style
and on sunday this sunday at 2 p.m
eastern
we're going to auction it off on nifty
gateway
and when we auction it off we're going
to take a portion of the proceeds and
we're going to donate it
to the new york city food bank oh wait i
didn't know that
oh you didn't no yeah that's awesome
yeah we're going to donate it
because guess what the reason why new
york is so amazing
is because of the new yorkers that live
there and so how do we help the people
in the city oh that's so nice so we're
gonna donate
a portion of proceeds to the new york
city food bank uh from the uh
auction but sunday 2 p.m eastern bang
bang
bang it's gonna be a big wait can i bid
two dollars sure you can start the
bidding off at two dollars
no no all right i will bid high and
fly let's just get to the lunchtime
hashtag ask lm in the comments lunch
money time guys
use hashtag askklm in the comments ask
us a question
and we'll likely respond to it lynn asks
hi anthony i'm lynn from vietnam i know
you i knew you from the rich chad poor
dad podcast in watched almost all of
your lunch money and interviews since
then
i'm very impressed by how smart and
knowledgeable you are can you share your
learning process
and experience thank you lin what's your
learning process like
i don't have a structured one i just
read and consume as much content as i
possibly can
like i'm generally curious and so what i
do is i spend a lot of time reading
through on twitter i try to curate a
bunch of
people that i think are really
interesting a lot of friends know the
things i'm interested in so they send me
stuff
i read all kinds of stuff on the
internet i actually don't read books as
much as i used to
um but that i'm trying to figure out why
that is
books are hard for business because it
changes all the damn time so if you're
reading a
business book from five years ago it's
likely things have already kind of
changed
that's true uh and then i listen to a
lot of podcasts
and my whole thing is just i generally
consume content
from the perspective that i want to have
an open mind and understand other
people's perspectives
so i don't necessarily go into it saying
hey i want to understand the truth
because the truth is really really hard
to uncover when you're reading
or consuming and you haven't thought
about it yet instead what i do is i want
to read things and say hey what does
paulina believe or what does
john believe or what does you know mary
believe and then i
as i consume that content i basically
take all these different pieces of
content and ideas
around a topic and then i formulate my
own idea
and a lot of times what i'll be able to
do is i'll be able to say something
you know to myself of like i want to
take this part of polina's argument but
i don't agree on the consequences of
that thing that she said
and i want to put it with john's you
know uh reading of if that thing happens
here's the
conclusion it's like the frankensteining
of ideas well
it's just trying to consume as much
content as possible and then sifting
through it and trying to find the things
that
make the most sense and what i find is
the more that i spread
like the spiderweb the more content i
consume
across different disciplines the more
likely it is that you actually start to
hone in
uh and find you know kind of quote truth
or what you believe
i will say anthony's one of the very few
people
if not the only person i know that knows
a lot about
different industries like from private
equity
to media to tech like i don't know
it's just for me it's hard to go deep on
a topic that i'm not necessarily that
familiar
with but he'll like sit and like read
all this stuff
on this one thing until he understands i
mean that's how you learn about bitcoin
yeah it's just just being curious trying
to understand things
and then what i like to do is then i
like to try to tell somebody about it so
that i know if i really understand it or
not because if i can explain it to you
then obviously i understand
one time we played this game where i was
like i'm gonna ask you a question
that you're not gonna know and i was
like
how are pencils made and he was like
well you see it
was like all right goodbye okay i'll do
everything no okay
that's because my questions weren't hard
enough i'll think of better ones all
right guys we'll see you tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget
lunch money is now sponsored by block
five so go check them out there's a link
in the description that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block my second favorite thing in the
world behind polina they've got three
products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends